for me the crown is hugely untypical
because normally I do feature films well
until recently I've been doing feature
films when you would come on board sort
of maybe 20 16 weeks before and then
you'd get something like 12 weeks
official prep or something maybe 16 if
you're lucky but with the crown I've
been on it for three and a half years
and that's the only time I've ever
looked back on my location recce
photographs and seeing how much younger
I was and I started it so I'll join
after Martin when he's done the initial
kind of concept work with the director
in the and looked at the script of
locations and then I kind of come in and
then do a second visit and we talked
about Hallett and colors and yeah how
are you how you want to you know go
ahead with it I'm very often by the time
you join by the time the set decorator
generally joins we have worked out which
bits we're shooting on location which
bits we're building and again that's
usually a simpler thing on a feature
film because the script is is there and
you can you know your knowledge of
locations means that you can work out
which are the obvious wants to go to and
which are the things you might like to
build and which are the things you know
you're gonna have to build whereas on
the crown it's much more of an evolving
thing so we're going back to sets that
we built three years ago that are now
being turned into other things twenty
years further on in their lifetime well
how do we work together with actually we
are we have discovered I think that we
have fairly stability but neither of us
wants to kind of show off you know we
very much want these sets to look like
they've been lived in and to make them
appropriate to what's going on in the
narrative because suddenly when as in
Episode four the one we've been
nominated for it's about a princess
deciding she doesn't really want to
wants to break out of the world of being
a princess now we've just had two
seasons of the crown where everything
has been extremely royal so we suddenly
get an opportunity to break out of being
not princesses but breaking out of a
kind of royal rut yes
nice to have an opportunity to to focus
on that distinction isn't it yes and
kind of layered look like Tony's Studios
yes exactly her move into sort of the
the bohemian world of the fifties more
than that royal world of the fifties but
that's this sort of royalness
this this richness we've been doing this
for several years and therefore we know
what what we want to do to get out of it
and we know how frustrated we've been by
not another gold big room well for me
because I'm I get joined quite early on
because of the scale of the work that we
have to do as designers so I get to know
the director and in the case of the
crown the directors and there are four
of them and very often at least two of
them usually three of them are working
component Lee so I have to kind of
divide my time between these between
these people well I've got there's a
great team I've kind of forgot last year
I think because of Martin to Sydney
there's a lot of sets being dressed
simultaneously up and down the country
because the locations are led by what
what there is you know in wheelchair or
north of England so a lot of
geographical strain in terms of kind of
covering the ground and we had got a
great production bar called Alison cardi
and some great assistants Sophia and
Lottie so there's a kind of a
controlling team of and at the prop
master as well just kind of trying to
logistics or trying to get everything to
the right place the right time and
covering it and making it look you know
the Marty the great advantage of the
longevity of the crown is that we kind
of gained a crew that things like we do
to put it to select slightly
oversimplify but they think like we do
so we just have big briefing sessions
together and we have walls for Alison's
walls are full of things she likes and
that a person
to the history of interior design I've
got walls that are full of similar
things the history of architecture over
this period I'm a bit more sort of stuck
in the research slightly but Martin has
a kind of a great wall of Hitchcock yes
kind of flavours and atmospheres yeah
it's a great thing to then absorb and
then try and interpret in a kind of
nuts-and-bolts kind of way you know
because at best I think you're you're
I'm part of the storytelling we are part
of the storytelling team as well
if this doesn't sound too immodest I've
got a sort of vast encyclopedic
knowledge of the history of film so I
know quite a bit about storytelling and
how those problems have been solved in
the past so I kind of go to that and
hook out a DVD and watch it with the
director and suddenly we'll get a little
Eureka moment as to how a problem might
be solved but that's more as a
storytelling problem and how the actors
and the storytelling might work within a
set but with regard to more logistical
problems I don't know do we have any do
we ever have any I think I think as long
as you've got good communication with
your crew and you risk I think the kids
respect everyone's roles and be grateful
and appreciative and then I think people
will go the extra mile for you - yeah
well we're sort of pulling in the same
direction we all want the same thing
mm-hmm
so it's logistical II I think that's
really important just have a great kind
of efficient good humoured Bunch
yeah and also welcome other people's
ideas you know so you know you want them
to be as creative as you are
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]